bound by flame is an RPG that takes you
to the world of their team al and
threatened by a lethal undead army led
by the seven ice Lords you are a
mercenary the last line of defense
against this unyielding evil ravaging
your world
it might help that you are being
possessed by a flame demon promising you
strength and powers will you reject the
demonic influence to keep your humanity
and your heroic abilities or let the
demon dominate yourself and unleash the
powers of the beast beware there is no
turning back
during your journey through their teeth
fantastical enemies will try to slow you
down don't underestimate them as there
are many creatures in this world more
ancient and dangerous than the hordes of
dead walkers
explore every corner of the map to
collect tons of weapons armor and
components to build incredible equipment
swords axis war hammers crossbows
daggers plenty of pieces of armor you
will have access to a vast array of
equipment entirely customizable thanks
to an intuitive craft system
progress through the story and the
numerous side quests will grant you
experience points to spend in your three
skill trees fight as a warrior and
unleash powerful attacks with your heavy
weapons be a formidable rogue and favor
a stealthy approach and fast-paced
combat style toggle between these combat
stances on the fly as the combat
situation evolves your demonic side will
also let you use devastating flame
spells transforming you into a feared
pyro master
during your journey you will meet five
different companions each has their own
specific story skills and character the
way you interact with them might have a
huge impact on your story and your
combat strategy
good luck on your quest vadiya and keep
tuned for the upcoming video that will
describe the dynamic combat system of
the game in more detail
you